okay so the big story of the day is of
course that parlor has now been banned
by apple google and amazon web services
which basically takes them offline so
this is an astonishing thing
it's an astonishing thing it should
scare the living hell out of all of you
it should it should scare you okay
because not only were they booted from
facebook
and booted from twitter they were also
booted
from the the apple store for example so
you couldn't download
the app they were they were booted from
google
so like all their platforms and then
worst of all
amazon shut parlor down from its cloud
hosting service that's amazon web
services right which is basically the
servers they took away all their servers
and they said you can't use our servers
anymore so it's one thing to remove it
from your app store it's another thing
to say
you literally cannot exist online
because we are taking your servers away
from you right you no longer
get to have your servers now imagine
just for a second
if in the middle of the black lives
matter riots and they were riots
they happened in hundreds of places
around the country imagine
if in the middle of the black lives
matter riots facebook
had been kicked off of its web hosting
services it had been kicked off of the
app store by apple
because people were using facebook to
organize protests that devolved into
riot
and people were probably making comments
on there that were really bad let's say
they were doing that which we know they
were
or instagram where people were
coordinating their activity or let's say
that twitter which has been used for
more violent threats against me
personally than any other app
well let's say that that they're web
serving that amazon web servers just
decided you know what
nope no more twitter the reaction would
be wow that sounds
really really scary and fascist in fact
to de-platform
entire applications because people were
misusing the application
cuts directly against the culture of
free speech not the legal of free speech
the culture of free speech
again these companies have a right to do
what they are doing but as we'll
we will talk about in a second when
you're talking about monopolistic
collusion which is really what this
looks like
i am as anti-regulation as any person as
any person in america
but you got to be worried about this and
you should be worried about this because
again
to be kicked off your server like here
was the idea the idea was okay you
didn't like twitter go build an
alternative
right i said it i said it many times i
said i don't want twitter regulated i
want an alternative
so parlor came up now i'm not going to
vouch for powerless policies
i don't know parlor's policies but i do
know that what you cannot do is force
people off a platform like twitter
you know you blew people off or you
alienate people so they build an
alternative
and then you remove the alternative
right everybody should go elsewhere
they said and they say okay so build
your own twitter like okay so we'll
build our own twitter they go build
parlor
and then like well you know what amazon
web services doesn't have to support you
so you need to go build your own server
farm
and after that you know what you need to
do you need to go build your own fiber
optic infrastructure
maybe what you need to do and if you
can't find a bank to lend you maybe you
need to build your own banks
well maybe you do maybe that's where all
of this is going
but imagine for just a second if this
had happened around blm and not around a
conservative oriented platform
imagine for a second that again facebook
had been d platform because people were
using facebook in order to coordinate
activity
in the middle of a pandemic by the way
that was going to violate not only law
but was also going to violate basic
precepts of human decency in the form of
riots
and so people have been like you know
what facebook's done we've just taken it
down people would be like wow that's
insane
but today the media are celebrating this
like openly openly celebrating this
the tech bros are taking a bad moment a
really bad moment for the country they
are making it significantly worse
because there is no consistent rule they
are applying here if we are talking
about apps that allow bad stuff to
happen on them twitter is like top of
the list
okay and and here is the thing that's
amazing so people talk a lot about
section 230.
i've said because legally this is
correct section 230 doesn't make a
distinction between platforms and
publishers what section 230 does
is it says you are not responsible for
open source posting on your website even
if you do some moderation of the open
source posting
right so if there's a comment sections
on daily wire daily wire is a
publication
we are responsible for what our editors
and writers put up but
if there's a comment section and then we
moderate it to get rid of for example
violent threats
then we still will not be held
responsible for the violent threat
for anything that happens in the
comments section now section 230 to
understand what it was about
originally it was well understood under
basic
precepts of american law that you don't
hold platforms accountable for how
people use the platforms
so for example everybody uses phones for
years
most crime was committed not online but
it was committed via phone right because
there was no internet so if you wanted
to commit a crime
you'd pick up the phone you'd use att
you'd call your criminal buddy and you'd
go rob a bank
was att responsible for that phone call
and the answer always was no
they're a platform they're not actively
encouraging you to commit that phone
call
right so att was a platform okay and
then
when it came to the internet that was
also the idea was these open source
platforms were not responsible for any
activity that happened that was illegal
on the uh it wasn't assumed to redound
to the liability of the company that
allowed the posting right if you had an
open source
and somebody posted a bad comment on
youtube or posted a bad comment on
twitter
or posted a bad comment in the daily
wire comment section none of those
places were responsible for the bad
comments that were posted it was just
the person who was responsible
for the bad comments that were posted
then some people said you know what
we need a better internet and there are
some places that actually do want to do
some comment moderation
so they want to get rid of for example
pornography in their comment section
they want to get rid of spam in their
comments section
does this make them liable because they
are now curating
and the answer section 230 said was no
it doesn't make them liable they're
allowed to do some of the curation to
make the comment sections better
okay now what has happened so the
baseline assumption there was that open
threads were not going to lead to
liability
right the moderation could lead to
liability so we removed the liability
from moderation
that's what section 230 was now we have
reversed it so now the idea is if you do
not moderate
you are liable so the only people who
are not liable in the cultural sphere
are the people who do not moderate so in
other words
only if you follow the the standards
the screening standards the the
fact-checking standards
or the informational standards of
twitter
or facebook or apple or amazon only if
you do that will you be allowed a
platform in the private sector
only if you do that will you be allowed
this okay that's an insane reversal of
the intent
of section 230 obviously which again was
meant to protect
a lot of these corporations from
liability because they were moderating
not in spite of their ma
not not because we wanted more
moderation but because we just wanted to
make sure that people who were
moderating weren't getting punished
extra
okay but now parlor has been dropped not
just by not just
by the apple store but also by
everyone right by apple by amazon web
services
now again i'm all in favor of the free
market
but you have to wonder about monopoly
practices here when the technological
instruments that are necessary for free
speech
are located basically in three companies
okay because in order for you to
be online in order for you to even host
a website you basically
are doing it through one of three
companies amazon microsoft which is
azure or google
right those are the three companies and
it really is mostly amazon amazon
controls
according to the uh according to the
firm stamford they control about 50
of all public cloud infrastructure
microsoft controls about 16 percent so
now you're up to 66 percent
google controls about four percent and
there are vast bevy of like tiny tiny
little firms that have a little bit
of public cloud infrastructure but not
nearly of the size and scope necessary
to actually allow pages to load fast
latency comes out and it's a real
problem
okay so you have these three companies
and not only are these three companies
controlling all of the
infrastructure which again that's okay
they are colluding in what they wish to
ban they're they're colluding in their
standards
even the consumer-based theory of
anti-monopoly which is one i subscribe
to right if it's not bad for consumers i
don't really care about monopoly
if the consumer-based theory is is true
it is very bad for consumers when all of
the companies are agreeing on the same
exact standard for what they will
platform and what they will not platform
because there are no alternatives
available
you know everybody on the right is
correctly concerned that this ain't
going to stop at parlor
they're saying a parlor didn't keep to
our moderating our moderating standards
let me tell you the moderating standards
and twitter are garbage they're pure
garbage the moderating standards at
facebook are a little better
not super a lot as by the way the left
has been saying
but everybody is worried where this is
going to go and they should be they're
worried that they're going to take down
podcasts like this one from the apple
store
they're worried they're going to take
down the daily wire app saying that it's
quote unquote misinformation on the
basis of both
fact checkers uh these these fact check
sites that are that are left-wing
oriented everybody is worried about that
and they should be worried about that
because that is where this is going
that is where this is going it's going
to get worse and worse and it's not
going to stop
they are going to de-platform everyone
here was parlor's ceo yesterday
saying we were dropped by every single
vendor
they made an attempt to not only kill
the apps
but to actually destroy the entire
company and it's not just these three
companies
every vendor from um
from text message services to email
providers
to our lawyers all ditched us too
on the same day and and then they're
trying to
uh falsely claim that we were somehow
responsible
for the events that occurred on the
sixth okay and this is what's going to
happen to company after company because
so long as the left can connect you to
violence so long as the left can even
make the argument
the left's goal is going to be to
deplatform you and ruin you personally
ruin your company
get you fired destroy you in your social
life
this is the tsunami the tsunami is here
okay so as i said at the beginning
go subscribe to your favorite sites
because you don't know when they're
going to be taken down
go help out the people who you want
information from because the tsunami is
coming and it is coming on fast it's
already come for parlor it is not going
to stop
at parlor now the question becomes what
replaces that
right what replaces that okay so here's
here's what replaces that what replaces
that
is the monopoly media where replaces
that is the re-establishment of the
monopoly
the monopoly media so that's been the
whole goal here right
why do you think there's so many members
of the new york times been stumping for
literally years the kara swishers and
kevin ruses of the world of the new york
times
stumping for years on end the jugular
gumball gums
all these people saying every outlet
that is not left wing should basically
be shut down deplatformed
marginalized all of these should be shut
down why
so they can re-establish control of all
methods of informational distribution
and then they can just control you see
we can have a happier america because we
all think the same right
we all think the same because we're
getting our information from the same
five sources
all of which are now the trusted news
sources over at facebook right facebook
has this
this quality control measure that they
were using in the last days of the
election
which naturally suggested that the
quality outlets were ones like cnn
and the non-quality outlets were ones
like you know the new york post because
they printed all that hunter biden stuff
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content